don't count your chickens before they're
hatched
many hands make light work
[Music]
a bad penny always turns up
[Music]
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
[Music]
actions speak louder than words
[Music]
you were never too old to learn
a picture is worth a thousand words
absence makes the heart grow fonder
grasp no more than thy hand will hold
[Music]
never judge by appearances
[Music]
a good beginning makes a good ending
birds of a feather flock together
half a loaf is better than no bread
if a job is worth doing it is worth
doing well
[Music]
there is none so blind as those who will
not see
[Music]
the early bird catches the worm
[Music]
honesty is the best policy
[Music]
into every life a little rain must fall
[Music]
beauty is only skin deep
[Music]
don't cross a bridge until you come to
it
let bygones be by guns
a stumble may prevent a fall
speak the truth and shame the devil
slow but sure
[Music]
don't put all your eggs in one basket
all that glitters is not gold
the grass is always greener on the other
side
[Music]
to everything there is a season
as you sow so shall you reap
two wrongs don't make a right
[Music]
better late than never
[Music]
one cannot make an omelette without
breaking eggs
[Music]
practice makes perfect
[Music]
there is no time like the present
hope for the best prepare for the worst
[Music]
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make him drink
there is no place like home
don't put off until tomorrow what you
can do today
[Music]
a bicycle can't stand on its own because
it's too tired
[Music]
if you want to judge a man's character
give him power
[Music]
if wishes were horses beggars might ride
[Music]
a stitch in time saves nine
[Music]
sticks and stones will break my bones
but names will never hurt me
life is what you make it
a man is as old as he feels himself to
be
it's a blessing in disguise
[Music]
least said is soonest mended
all good things come to he who waits
a trouble shared is a trouble haved
[Music]
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
you never know what you can do until you
try
[Music]
one father is more than a hundred
schoolmasters
[Music]
success has many fathers while failure
is an orphan
[Music]
one of these days is none of these days
[Music]
elbow grease is the best polish
proportion your expenses to what you
have not what you expect
[Music]
don't try to run before you can walk
[Music]
worry often gives a small thing a big
shadow
[Music]
all happiness is in the mind
[Music]
nothing ventured nothing gained
[Music]
it's never too late to mend
[Music]
patience wears away stones
[Music]
cheaters never win and winners never
cheat
knock on wood
[Music]
a good example is the best sermon
[Music]
some men go through a forest and see no
firewood
[Music]
do not be in a hurry to tie what you
cannot untie
[Music]
in for a penny in for a pound
[Music]
slow and steady wins the race
[Music]
don't cross your bridges before you get
to them
[Music]
lose an hour in the morning and you'll
be running after it all day
[Music]
action is the proper fruit of knowledge
[Music]
all good things come to those who wait
[Music]
a smooth sea never made a skilled
mariner
no woman gets an orgasm from shining the
kitchen floor
[Music]
you